here's a language and here's a brain and
this is a brain on language just look at
this brain in case you're not up to date
on all the science there's a whole lot
going on here there are neurons and
glial cells capillaries and myelinated
axons all this Anatomy but the sexiest
stuff to focus on has been the nerve
cells in your cerebral cortex that's
this outside layer here the inside looks
whitish this stuff looks grey hence the
terms white matter and grey matter the
first real evidence of the brain's role
in language came not from observing
normal healthy brains using language but
from damaged brains this started back in
the 1800s when pioneering researchers
dissected the brains of aphasiacs the
ancient Greek word apasa simply means
speechlessness patients suffering from
aphasia have head injuries that disrupt
their abilities to understand or produce
speech it turns out that specific
linguistic difficulties were associated
with lesions in specific parts of the
cortex the logic involved in pinning
down these language centers of the brain
is pretty simple if someone doing action
a has a healthy region B but someone
else was damaged to region B can't do a
then it looks like region B is necessary
for action a in 1861 a French surgeon
named M bull boca began to study the
brains of aphasiacs and hunted down just
such a region apparently crucial for
speech production a region we today
called Broca's area inspired by Broca's
findings a German doctor and anatomist
Carl von nikka Winton found another such
region this one linked to linguistic
understand
as you might have guessed that region is
called Venegas area a little side note
for you anatomy buffs or anyone looking
for extra credit today's most widely
used system for cutting the brain into
regions was proposed by another German
anatomist Corbin Ian Broadman this outer
surface of the brain we've been admiring
has over two dozen of these Broadman
areas
Broca's corresponds to Broadman areas 45
and 44 while 22 is home to Veronicas
area in your brain specifically both of
these regions are most likely in your
left hemisphere with all of the
technological leaps forward we've made
in brain imaging since Broca's day
looking inside the brain to see what's
lighting up where has obviously become
even more important but don't let the
aphasiacs mislead you what we're
searching for inside the brain isn't
necessarily straightforward the way
researchers speak about it it's not as
if neuroimaging gives us the exact brain
location of language or of love or any
other human concept instead we get to
see the areas of the brain the
activation of the actual brain cells
that are involved in performing a task
these days there are two fields that
tackle our topic of the day which is
language on the brain and Chris you've
already forgotten the first one
neurolinguistics makes an entire
discipline out of the kind of research
we've been chatting about
psycholinguistics a related field as the
name implies is crazy about language but
it takes on general questions like how
do humans acquire language and how do
humans speak and understand with a focus
on the role of the mind in these
activities the two fields inform each
other meaning that there's a high degree
of interdisciplinarity here with all
this stuff about the brain going through
your brain think for a minute about two
twentieth-century models of language
in model number one human language is a
collection of behaviors that are
conditioned by external stimuli verbal
behavior language that gets a favorable
response will be reinforced and repeated
this is a perspective called behaviorism
and it places the brain in a background
role model number two is a very popular
linguistic model of language known as
nativism it holds that language is an
innate mental faculty grammar isn't just
a linguistic concept anymore it's
actually born into every healthy human
brain but instead of marginalizing the
brain by focusing on external behavior
and operant conditioning and instead of
bringing linguistics to the brain by
mapping grammatical concepts onto brain
areas perhaps we could be a little more
considerate of what the brain is
actually doing when we articulate our
understanding of language yes being that
specific with our familiar general
academic terms will require a bit more
intellectual muscle than ignoring the
brain or slapping stickers like language
grammar speech on to some part of your
cortex but consider it an invitation an
invitation to get to know your brain and
your brain on language a bit better
thanks for learning with me
you